und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend wie wird europa aus der krise
herauskommen eines ist sicher es hilft
nicht wenn nur deutschland dank guter
ausgangsbedingungen und große muss diese
pandemie einigermaßen übersteht das
nutzt sonst am ende nur wenig wenn
unsere wichtigsten handelspartner
reihenweise in die knie gehen und der
euro kollabiert nun will der zufall ist
dass deutschland quasi mitten in der
krise die europäische
ratspräsidentschaft übernimmt sie geht
turnusgemäß ab ersten juli in berlin ein
halbes jahr lang die angela merkel diese
aufgabe sieht beschrieb sie heute in
einer regierungserklärung vor dem
bundestag
was die kanzlerin sagte und welche
kritik von der opposition gibt hat armin
coerper für uns beobachtet eigentlich
kann merkel krise nach 15 jahren glaubt
man dass zumindest was macht es da schon
dass das programm für ihre zweite
deutsche rats präsidentschaft noch gar
nicht komplett abgestimmt ist die
pandemie beherrscht europa eine krise
eben just wenn merkel übernimmt und die
definiert an europa in abgrenzung die
antidemokratischen kräften die radikalen
autoritären bewegen warten ja nur auf
ökonomische krisen um sie dann politisch
zu missbrauchen
sie warten
wenn sich jemand angesprochen zu fühlen
man hat eben die rollen eingenommen
lange schon
merkel will europa nach der pandemie
krise mit einem milliardenpaket retten
replik spitze schlagabtausch so läuft
das im hohen haus unserem land droht
eine nie dagewesene welle von
arbeitslosigkeit unternehmenspleiten der
mittelstand verarmt und in dieser
situation haben wir auch keine
milliarden zu verschenken denn wir
müssen uns selbst helfen wäre dieser
phase in dieser entscheidenden phase
europas davon spricht dass deutschland
die melkkuh ist weil wir uns finanziell
engagieren
der muss aufpassen dass er nicht zu
diesen parlament wird wissen sie mal wer
sie schieben sollte herr gauland der
vorsitzende einer partei deren position
der partei die dich entschieden haben
wir sie führt demokraten oder neonazis
doch die krise sieht diesmal anders aus
als sonst
die wirtschaft ist fast zum stillstand
gekommen über 100.000 menschen in europa
haben in der pandemie ihr leben verloren
und das leben in europa ist nicht mehr
wie bisher
die panini und der mit ihr verbundene
wirtschaftseinbruch sind die größte
herausforderung in der geschichte
europas wie europa im vergleich zu
anderen regionen der welt diese krisen
bewältigt
das wird über den wohlstand der
europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger
entscheiden und über europas rolle in
der welt
so hat das programm quasi die pandemie
verfasst europa aus der krise führen
ökologisch und sozial
zum ersten mal soll die eu-kommission
dafür auch schulden aufnehmen dürfen und
die opposition wünscht sich was
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben jetzt die
chance die richtigen weichen zu stellen
nutzen sie um die eu zu einer
gemeinschaft zu machen in der nicht
soziale spaltung aufrüstung und
abschottung ganz oben stehen im
rückblick soll man sagen es war keiner
ratspräsidentschaft der neuen schulden
es war eine ratspräsidentschaft der
neuen arbeitsplätze so vergleichsweise
gut wie wir in deutschland durch die
krise gekommen sind wären wir doch
prädestiniert dafür beim klimaschutz
jetzt wirklich eine führende rolle zu
übernehmen
doch eine ratspräsidentschaft verlangt
auch nach standortbestimmung
krisenbewältigung ist das eine doch wo
steht deutschland in europa und was hat
man aus krisen gelernt
wir müssen auch zugeben die pandemie hat
offengelegt wie fragil das europäische
projekt noch ist die ersten reflexe auch
unsere eigenen waren eher national und
nicht durchgehend europäisch vieles
klang seltsam bekannt in dieser debatte
doch die herausforderung steht im raum
in den nächsten sechs monaten wird sich
zeigen ob merkel wirklich krise können
angela merkel und emanuel mackrodt
treibt nicht nur die wirtschaftliche
zukunft europas und der innere
zusammenhalt der eben auch welche rolle
die europäer in der weltpolitik spielen
werden wohin das auge reicht sind auf
der weltbühne ja schwierige zeit
genossen unterwegs das verhältnis zu
russland etwa ist denkbar schlecht
geworden in berlin paris brüssel
beobachtet man sehr genau welche
attacken aus moskau kommen nicht nur in
form von hackern und digitaler
propaganda in berlin sorgte zuletzt auch
der sogenannte tiergarten mord für
empörung
heute wurde anklage gegen den
tatverdächtigen erhoben und die
bundesregierung droht russland mit
maßnahmen wobei offen ist welche das
sein können und was sie bewirken aus
berlin andreas kühner ist
es fängt mit den begriffen an das
auswärtige amt hätte den botschafter
russlands ein bestellen können
diplomaten deutsch für die leviten lesen
aber sergej netschajew ist am nachmittag
wie es heißt zum gespräch eingeladen
diplomaten deutsch für zum gespräch
eingeladen wenn die bundesregierung vor
diesem hintergrund nicht einmal den
russischen botschafter einbestellt
sondern nur auf eine nette tasse kaffee
einlädt dann zeigt dass der russischen
regierung für uns ist das neue normal
wenn man bei uns vor der haustür
menschen ermorden lässt das ist der
ermordete menschen ikk russischer
staatsfeind der in tschetschenien gegen
russland kämpfte und in georgien schon
einen anschlag überlebt hat aus dem
anderen am hellichten freitag 23 august
wird eine tiefe deutsch-russische krise
weil der mann der den flüchtigen
milizenchef mutmaßlich erschießt ein
auftragsmörder gewesen sein soll für den
generalbundesanwalt erteilten staatliche
stellen der zentralregierung der
russischen föderation dem
angeschuldigten den auftrag
wir haben heute den russischen
botschafter erneut zu einem gespräch ins
auswärtige amt eingeladen um der
russischen seite unserer haltung noch
einmal unmissverständlich darzulegen und
die bundesregierung behält sich weitere
maßnahmen in diesem fall ausdrücklich
vor eingeladen vorbehalten die reaktion
der bundesregierung ist auffällig
moderat weil moskau die deutschen
rechtshilfeersuchen nicht beantwortet
hat deutschland zwar zwei russische
diplomaten ausgewiesen aber in einem
ganz ähnlichen fall dem mordversuch am
russischen überläufer sergej skripal in
england schmiss berlin vier diplomaten
raus und london sogar 23 das war eine
sehr harte reaktion es wurden
gleichzeitig aus verschiedenen ländern
russische diplomaten ausgewiesen das war
ein skandal
theoretisch müssten wir hier etwas
ähnliches erwarten
als nicht gerechtfertigt und haltlos
lässt russlands botschaft in berlin alle
vorwürfe dementieren unvergessen
allerdings wie präsident putin nicht den
täter sondern das opfer kritisierte
zetsche jüngst
dieser mann wurde von uns gesucht er war
ein bandit ein brutaler blutrünstiger
mensch die bundesregierung muss jetzt
ernsthafte konsequenzen ziehen und
endlich auch mit den europäischen
partnern das gespräch suchen gemeinsam
gegenüber russland zu reagieren
das ist die gemeinsame forderung heute
von grünen fdp und cdu
das ist aber noch nicht die haltung der
bundesregierung
die europäer müssen sie sich nicht nur
gedanken darüber machen was ihr großer
nachbar im osten so alles treibt
hinzu kommt dass gegenüber russland die
usa keine absolut verlässliche
schutzmacht mehr sind doch donald trump
stellt das westliche bündnis ja nicht
nur militärisch in frage
auch bei der verteidigung westlicher
werte taugt washington nicht mehr als
führungsmacht die erkenntnis ist nicht
neu doch die neuesten enthüllungen die
in washington jetzt für aufregung sorgen
unterfüttern das nochmal matthiesen
berichtet
am rande des g20 dinner vor einem jahr
versuchte donald trump angeblich sich
einmal mehr selbst zu helfen
dabei hat er keine berührungsängste vor
autokraten wenn sie ihm nutzen bringen
den chinesischen präsidenten shiva trump
an jenem abend um hilfe für seine
wiederwahl so jedenfalls beschreibt es
john bolton in seinem buch 500 seiten
über trumps wesen und treiben
er bat sie ihn ständig sicherzustellen
dass er gewinnt china sollte ganz viele
agrarprodukte kaufen um trump die
stimmen der farmer zu sich bolton war
nah dran am us präsidenten deshalb haben
seine worte gesicht trump soll sie auch
bestärkt haben figuren aus der
muslimischen minderheit in china in
lager zu sperren
er habe gesagt dass sie mit dem bau der
lager fortfahren sollte es sei genau die
richtige sache die zu tun sei trump so
bolten sei nur auf seine wiederwahl aus
machthaber wie putin finden das eher
nützlich gut hin glaubt dass er trump
wie eine fibel spielen kann
putin ist fluch und harte und sieht im
tram keinen ernsthaften widersacher
bolton schreibt das seinem früheren chef
fototermine wichtiger sind als der
politische flurschaden den sie anrichten
aber das wie vieles andere im buch ist
eigentlich nichts neues
trotzdem ist trump wütend über die
enthüllungen seines ex mitarbeiters er
hat das gesetz gebrochen ganz einfach
das ist streng geheim die höchste stufe
streng geheime informationen
das justizministerium will deshalb nun
den verkauf des buchs noch gerichtlich
stoppen die chancen stehen schlecht denn
der präsident selbst bezeichnet die
inhalte ja als lügen und pure fiktion
erfundene geschichten aber können keine
staatsgeheimnisse sein
das alles macht bolton nicht zum helden
denn er hätte ja in seinem
amtsenthebungsverfahren aussagen können
vielleicht wäre es anders ausgegangen
stattdessen schrieb holten dann ein buch
und kassierte dafür zwei millionen
danke john bolton dass sie als
feuerwehrmann helfen wollen nachdem das
haus längst abgebrannt ist
er hätte als patriot nach vorn treten
können beim prozess gegen den
präsidenten stattdessen rannte er weg
und versteckte sich beobachtungen aus
nächster nähe sind ja oft die
schädlichsten und noch ist ramms bücher
sommer nicht zu ende
das von seiner nichte mary trump kommt
im juli zu viel und nie genug die meine
familie den gefährlichsten mann der welt
erschuf darin angeblich geheime
dokumente über die finanzen eines
präsidenten dem der eigennutz über alles
andere geht
trump so hört man die seine nichte nun
auch verklagen
zurück nach deutschland wie soll es nach
den ferien mit den schulen weiter gehen
mit dem thema beginnt die nachrichten
halten
die kultusminister der länder haben in
einer video-konferenz den beschluss
gefasst die regelung zum mindestabstand
von 1 meter 50 soll ab dem neuen
schuljahr entfallen
vorausgesetzt das infektionsgeschehen
lasse das zu es brauche wieder einen
regulären schulbetrieb nach geltender
stundentafel so die präsidentin der
kultusministerkonferenz sich damit das
recht auf bildung gewährleistet werden
können
in einem nächsten schritt müssten
aktualisierte schutz und
hygienemaßnahmen vereinbart werden
nach einem neuen massiven corona
ausbruch in göttingen haben die behörden
einen kompletten hochhauskomplex für
eine woche unter quarantäne gestellt da
viele der bewohner kontakt untereinander
hätten könne man nur so infektionsketten
unterbrechen etwa 700 menschen sind
betroffen
nach ersten tests wurden unter ihnen
bereits etwa 100 neue infektionen
nachgewiesen
für die bewohner werde unter anderem ein
mobiles medizinisches versorgungszentrum
aufgebaut nachdem krone ausbruch in
einem schlachtbetrieb im landkreis
gütersloh gibt es nach angaben der
kreisverwaltung inzwischen 730
bestätigte infektionen
nordrhein westfalens gesundheitsminister
karl josef laumann hat eine eingehende
ursachenerforschung angekündigt laumann
sagte der frankfurter allgemeinen
zeitung sein ministerium werde eine
wissenschaftliche studie in auftrag
geben die dem ausbruchsgeschehen
epidemiologisch auf den grund geht es
müsse untersucht werden wie die korona
ausbrüche in der fleischindustrie
entstehen
wer im internet nur den sozialen medien
hetzt und menschen bedroht muss künftig
mit deutlich härteren strafen rechnen
so gilt etwa bereits die androhung von
körperverletzungen und sexuellen
übergriffen
nach einem beschluss des bundestages
künftig als straftat dafür können
freiheitsstrafen von bis zu zwei jahren
verhängt werden
justizministerin christine lambrecht
sagte das seien entschlossene schritte
gegen menschen und demokratie feinde die
ein gefährliches klima der gewalt
schürten
der bundesgerichtshof hat den
schuldspruch wegen mordes gegen einen
der beiden berliner autoraser bestätigt
das urteil gegen der zweiten fahrer
wurde dagegen aufgehoben
die beiden männer waren 2016 bei einem
illegalen autorennen mit tempo 170 über
den kudamm gerast einer rammte das auto
eines rentners der noch an der
unfallstelle starb
aus sicht des bgh habe der fahrer
billigend in kauf genommen dass durch
seine besonders gefährliche fahrweise
auch menschen zu tode kommen können
der fall des zweiten angeklagten muss
hingegen neu verhandelt werden der
europäische gerichtshof hat erneut ein
gesetz in ungarn beanstandet es betrifft
den umgang mit
nicht-regierungsorganisationen gegen das
gesetz hatten 2017 tausende protestieren
er schreibt unter anderem vor dass sich
entschloss die spenden aus dem ausland
erhalten
ab einem bestimmten schwellenwert
registrieren lassen müssen
der euro habe urteilt die regelungen als
diskriminierend
zu den vielen nicht zu verdauen
umständen bei den zuletzt aufgedeckten
fällen brutalen kindesmissbrauchs in
münster gehört dass der mutmaßliche
haupttäter einschlägig vorbestraft war
er hatte bereits in der vergangenheit
gewaltvideos mit kindern verbreitet
zweimal stand er deshalb vor gericht und
erhielt nur bewährungsstrafen und später
schaute niemand genauer hin wie dieser
mann mit seiner lebensgefährtin und
deren kind lebte das kind gehört auch zu
den opfern
das wirft fragen auf mit denen sich
heute der bundestag befasst hat nach
schärferen gesetzen härteren strafen und
mehr sorgfalt im umgang mit auffällig
gewordenen täter britta spiekermann
berichtet der kindesmissbrauch in
münster er zieht weitere kreise
inzwischen sind es 18 tatverdächtige
sieben sitzen in untersuchungshaft
es sind mindestens sechs opfer im
kindesalter die kühlen zahlen stehen für
schwerste verbrechen kinder immer wieder
missbraucht ermittler die unbeirrt
spuren folgten auf empörung und
entsetzen soll diesmal konkretes
politisches handeln folgen die
innenminister heute in erfurt das thema
kindesmissbrauch ganz oben auf der
politischen agenda härtere strafen null
toleranz das ist ein verbrechen das ist
sowas macht und muss auch so behandelt
werden hände aus es ist ein ganz
widerliches verbrechen dass unsere
gemeinschaft
viel viel stärker bestrafen muss als das
in der vergangenheit der fall war
es ist auch ein vorwurf an die
bundesjustizministerin härtere strafen
lambrecht hatte gezögert geriet unter
druck schwenkte ein
bei sexuellem missbrauch soll es künftig
keine differenzierung mehr geben
zwischen vergehen und verbrechen
zum beispiel dadurch dass es einen
minderschweren fall wie bisher von
schweren kindesmissbrauch in zukunft
nicht mehr geben wird meine damit dass
anfängliche zögern der ministerin in der
vergangenen woche für die afg stoff
genug für konsequenzen der forderung der
deutschen kinderhilfe nur anschließen v
lamprecht treten sie zurück die debatte
reicht von einer rücktrittsforderung bis
hin zu breite rückendeckung
einhellig die meinung es muss härter
verurteilt werden verbunden mit einer
mahnung ist die ultima ratio zur
bewältigung gesellschaftlicher konflikt
da sie das letzte mittel und deshalb
sollte über strafrechtsverschärfungen
mit kühlem kopf und nicht mit heißen
herzen beraten werden lambrecht will
jetzt dass es schnell geht nächste woche
einen gesetzentwurf und auch die
familienministerin schaltet sich ein
will eine millionenschwere
aufklärungskampagne
alleine die tatsache dass statistisch in
jeder schulklasse ein bis zwei kinder
betroffen sind wenn wir nur das hellfeld
betrachten und daneben auch noch mal
eins dunkelfeld weitergehen das heißt es
es ist so dass jeder von uns
wahrscheinlich mit kindern zu tun hatte
schon mal die betroffenen sind ich werde
mich sehr dafür einsetzen dass der schub
im kampf gegen sexuellen missbrauch der
jetzt durch den missbrauchsfall münster
zu sehen ist dass der nachhaltig wird
der kampf gegen sexuelle gewalt an
kindern und jugendlichen ist eine
nationale daueraufgabe tatort münster
nach jedem missbrauchsskandal entflammte
debatte aufs neue um schnell wieder zu
erlöschen diesmal soll es anders sein
was sexualisierte gewalt gegen kinder
angeht denkt man ja man habe inzwischen
von allen varianten der grausamkeit
gehört die da begangen werden furchtbare
videos die in großem stil produziert
werden
systematischer missbrauch in heimen
unter dem dach der kirche und sogar dass
eltern ihre eigenen kinder regelrecht
verkaufen all solche taten sind
vollständig unfassbar
aber man hat erfahren müssen dass es all
das tatsächlich gab und gibt der bericht
gleich von stephanie heine über den
händlerskandal zeigt allerdings noch mal
eine andere variante nämlich das
systematische und absichtsvolle zuführen
von kindern an sexualtäter das
staatliche instanzen durch die berliner
senatsverwaltung und jugendämter und das
ganze wurde auch noch pädagogisch
wissenschaftlich ermittelt er galt als
renommierter wissenschaftler psychologe
sexual experte helmut kändler
einflussreiche in berliner
sozialbehörden seit mitte der 1960 er
jahre angestellt am pädagogischen
zentrum des landes aktiv mit einem
angeblich reformorientierten experiment
scheinbar im interesse von jugendlichen
und pflege vätern unter diesem
deckmantel der wissenschaft ist ihm
gelungen ein netzwerk zu zu spannen und
unter dem label experiment und was
absolut kein experiment war sondern zwar
wirklich kriminell was da stattgefunden
hat das eben kinder an pädophile
pflegefehler vermittelt worden sind
strukturen die über jahrzehnte hielten
er hat das erlebt möchte nicht erkannt
werden wir nennen ihn marco als
fünfjähriger kam marco zu einem
pflegevater der laut einer studie zu
helmut kennt das netzwerk gehörte die
berliner behörden haben immer wieder
jungen hier untergebracht marco war mit
einem pflege bruder dar
tagein tagaus und wissen doch auch
wieder harte weise wirklich gewaltig war
bei mir von 15 bezirksligen vom 6
siebzehnten lebensjahr einmal die woche
kindeswohlgefährdung in öffentlicher
verantwortung nennt das die aktuelle
untersuchung der uni hildesheim über
helmut händlers wirken und stellt fest
es bestätigen eine ganze reihe von
zeitzeugen dass die grundkonstruktion
wohngemeinschaften oder pflegestellen
bei pädophilen männern einzurichten
in der senatsverwaltung bekannt war und
durchaus auch in bezirks jugendämtern
nicht bei allen auf akzeptanz gestoßen
ist
die kinder von damals heute erwachsen
wie viele solcher pflegestellen es gab
wie viele kinder dort gelitten haben
noch völlig unklar
das problem offenbar keine rein berliner
angelegenheit
es gibt ganz deutliche hinweise dass
auch andere jugendämter in
westdeutschland involviert waren und
dieses netzwerk gilt es weiter zu
untersuchen und aufzuarbeiten
wir sehen aber auch einen anderen zweig
der hier ganz wichtig ist und über den
wir viel zu wenig sprechen nämlich
akademische institutionen pädagogische
institution die berliner jugend
senatorin will aktuell die
qualitätssicherung bei pflegestellen
überprüfen aus den fehlern ihrer
vorgänger lernen das hat alles auch
unter verantwortung der behörden
stattgefunden und deswegen hat das land
berlin auch um entschuldigung gebeten
und das land berlin wird hier auch eine
entschädigung den opfern zahlen in
markus pflegestelle waren bis zu beginn
der 2000er jahre insgesamt zehn kinder
und jugendliche untergebracht
er wäre durchaus bereit über
entschädigung zu reden aber auf
augenhöhe sollte das passieren
ein bittsteller der almosen empfängt
will er nicht sein
um missbrauchte kinder geht es nachher
auch in der gesprächsrunde von maybrit
illner und ihren gästen die über
besseren schutz und härtere strafen
diskutieren wir bei allen berichten über
geflüchtete die an europas küsten
anlanden oder über land einwandern im
globalen maßstab ist das nur ein sehr
kleiner
der menschen die weltweit auf der flucht
sind nachdem zahlen die das
flüchtlingshilfswerk der vereinten
nationen heute veröffentlichte sind das
aktuell fast 80 millionen menschen so
viele wie seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
nicht mehr
der überwiegende teil von ihnen sind
binnenflüchtlinge die innerhalb ihres
staates bleiben aber aus ihren
heimatorten vertrieben wurden und
diejenigen die landesgrenzen
überschreiten werden so über 80 prozent
von entwicklungsländern aufgenommen die
selbst arm sind in der sahel region etwa
burkina faso ist ein kleines armes und
keineswegs sicheres land und zugleich
ziel vieler flüchtlinge hat so ein
bericht von tim kröger das
flüchtlingscamp debüt im norden burkina
fasos tausende menschen aus mali haben
hier zuflucht gesucht als islamisten vor
einigen jahren den norden ihrer heimat
übernahmen fanden sicherheit zunächst im
märz aber mussten sie das camp verlassen
attacken und drohungen durch bewaffnete
gruppen versetzten auch miriam valletta
denn und ihre kinder in angst und
schrecken
es sind die gleichen probleme die die
menschen schon aus mali vertrieben haben
sie hörten schüsse während sie schliefen
menschen starben die gleichen probleme
sind im camp gute buch angekommen
auch marco wiese und seine familie
finden keine ruhe
sie flüchteten vor acht jahren aus mali
seit 2017 aber wurde die sicherheitslage
in burkina faso von jahr zu jahr immer
schwieriger sagt er
krippen und annahmen meint sogar meinen
sohn haben sie entführt bis heute habe
ich nichts von ihm gehört
hier im norden burkina fasos sind die
flüchtlinge gefangen im chaos und der
gewalt der region die sich immer weiter
ausbreiten
islamistische terrorgruppen
selbstverteidigungs milizen banditen
ethnische konflikte schwache staatliche
strukturen armee gewalt die normalen
menschen leiden am meisten
in burkina faso sind längst auch
hunderttausende einheimische auf der
flucht und die kurve pandemie macht
alles noch schwieriger sagt monique
rudakow bora vom flüchtlingshilfswerk
der vereinten nationen
die situation in den dörfern wird
schlimmer menschen flüchtlinge
binnenvertriebene kommen nach wie vor
ort werden überfallen es scheint als
könnte corona diesen unbekannten
bewaffneten gruppen nichts anhaben und
von burkina faso aus könnten terror und
gewalt weitere länder erfassen wenn das
land weiter abdriftet sagen experten
was wir vor allem fürchten müssen ist
dass bei den bevorstehenden wahlen denn
wir sehen deutlich dass sich die
situation verschlechtert dass der staat
die kontrolle verliert elegant in die
pendler control keine aussicht auf
besserung für die flüchtlinge also für
den 62-jährigen maccabees und seine
familie eine verzweifelte lage wenn es
frieden in mali gibt werde ich
zurückkehren aber solange es dort keinen
frieden gibt kann ich nicht sagen dass
ich das tun werde
dabei wünscht er sich nicht viel nur
sicherheit und genug zum überleben für
seine familie und ich uns jetzt nochmal
mit anderen meldungen zunächst noch eine
korrektur zur meldung des bgh urteils im
auto raser prozess war leider ein
falsches bild aus dem verfahren zum
mordfall lübke eingeblendet das bitten
wir zu entschuldigen
zur börse da hat bei den dax-werten
heute die aktienkursentwicklung eines
unternehmens deutlich herausgeragt nach
unten
es waren die papiere des
zahlungsabwicklers wirecard sina mainitz
was war der grund dafür
bereits zum vierten mal wurde die
präsentation der bilanzzahlen von
wirecard heute verschoben
transparenz sieht anders aus hinzu kommt
dass knapp zwei milliarden euro von
treuhandkonten offenbar verschwunden
sein sollen
anleger haben heute schon scharenweise
wirecard den rücken gekehrt um mehr als
60 prozent
der kurs des finanzdienstleisters ab das
war der zweitgrösste tagesverlust eines
dax-unternehmens den es je gab
innerhalb eines tages wurden damit 7,6
milliarden euro an börsenwert vernichtet
schon fragen sich einige ob das münchner
unternehmen nun die erste börsenliga
vielleicht bald verlassen muss
man bekommt hier als analyst
schnappatmung auf der einen seite haben
wir ein tolles unternehmen das ja bei
digitalen zahl systemen führend ist auch
weltweit führend ist und da passiert so
was mit bilanz vorwürfen mit
liquiditätsengpässen eventuell mit
unklaren verhältnissen das darf nicht
passieren
das geschäftsmodell von wirecard ist
absolut zukunftsfähig und mit
fortschreitender digitalisierung mehr
gefragt denn je das geschäftsgebaren des
unternehmens ist es nicht
wirecard hat viel vertrauen verspielt
heute folgten personelle konsequenzen
der vorstand für das organisatorische
geschäft wurde bereits freigestellt die
finanzaufsicht bafin und die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen ermittelt nun
weiter
sina mainitz vielen dank die kontrollen
von investitionen aus dem
nicht-eu-ausland in deutschland werden
verschärft das hat der bundestag
beschlossen wirtschaftsminister altmaier
sagte deutschland sei weiter offen für
ausländische investitionen aber der
staat wolle auch wissen wer dahinter
stehe falls erforderlich müssten
deutsche und europäische unternehmen
geschützt werden vor unfairem wettbewerb
und zulässigen technologietransfer und
vor einem aufkauf durch staatlich
subventionierte konkurrenz noch eine
meldung vom fußball leipzig top torjäger
timo werner wechselnd noch im juli zu
chelsea london
der 24 jährige wird mit dem transfer zum
teuersten deutschen fußballer der
geschichte
die ablöse beträgt 53 millionen euro
auf seiner twitter-seite sendete der
deutsche nationalspieler schon ein
grußwort an die chelsea fans
er sagte zudem es sei schon immer sein
traum gewesen einmal in der premier
league
der stärksten liga der welt zu spielen
das war es von uns und wie eben schon
angekündigt folgt jetzt maybrit illner
mit ihren gästen und um 0 uhr 30 meldet
sich daniel bröckerhoff mit hatte plus
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren seit tagen
das gleiche spiel immer liegt dieses
wolkenband über uns und das sieht nur
ganz allmählich weiter nach norden
es bringt deswegen kräftige regenfälle
mit und auch gewitter auch wieder in
dieser nacht da wegen des besonders
kräftig zwischen weser und elbe und es
sind auch einzelne gewitter noch dabei
sonst lockern die wolken auf und in der
feuchten luft bildet sich auch mal nebel
auch aus den alpen heraus ganz einige
regenschauer geben
unter diesen regen und gewitterwolken im
nordosten aber bleibt die nacht mit mit
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 16 und 14
grad
sonst sinken die werte auf 13 bis 9 grad
und morgen liegen sie dann recht
einheitlich in deutschland um die 20
grad am kühlsten bleibt es am alpenrand
und im allgäu mit 17 grad am wärmsten
wird es am niederrhein mit 24 grad und
es schüttelt morgen ergiebig weiter in
norddeutschland innerhalb von 24 stunden
können durchaus an die 50 liter regen
pro quadratmeter fallen
und in diesem streifen zwischen süd und
berlin sind auch einzelne gewitter dabei
deutlich freundlicher sieht das aus
richtung ruhrgebiet aber auch über der
rhön oder dem oberpfälzer wald scheint
häufiger die sonne
besonders am nachmittag kann es
allerdings ganz im süden noch einige
regenschauer und gewitter liegen das
aber wird sich ändern und dass sie an
einem neuen tiefe dem atlantik denn das
bringt sehr milde luft richtung
mitteleuropa ja sommerluft kommt dann
anfang der woche
das zeigen schon unsere aussichten am
montag steigen die temperaturen bis 27
grad schön ab